بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على معلمنا الاول سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه اجمعين
حضرتك صاحب الجلاله الهاشميه الملك عبد
الله الثاني بن الحسين اصحاب الفخامه
والسمو المعالي والسعاده والحضور الكريم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
يطيبوا لي بدايه ان نتقدم بالشكر والتقدير
المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه للدعوه لهذا
المؤتمر وشكر موصول لكافه القائمين عليه
على حسن الاستقبال والتنظيم
مقدمين التعازي للاردن الشرقيه باستشهاد
رجال الامن خلال ادائهم من الواجب ومؤكدين
على وقوفنا الكامل الى جانب الاردني
الشقيق ودعمنا لكافه يهودي المبذوله
لحمايه امينه واستقرار
اصحاب الفخامه
ياتي انعقاد النسخه الثانيه من مؤتمر
بغداد للتعاون والشراكه بعد عام من نسخته
الاولى التي عقدت في بغداد في اغسطس 20 21
ومنذ ذلك التاريخ شاهد العالم ومنطقتنا
جمله من المتغيرات وتحديات الا ان الجهود
الجماعيه لتعزيز السلام والامن والاستقرار
في منطقتنا ودفع جهود البناء والتنميه بما
يلبي تطلعات شعوبها بالرخاء والازدهار
تبقى دائما على سلم اولوياتنا وقمه
اهتماماتنا
ولقد اولى الدول مجلس التعاوني
اهتماما كبيرا بتعزيز علاقتها مع جمهوريه
العراق من خلال السيل بناء شراكه
استراتيجيه وثيقه في كافه المجالات
انطلاقا مما يربط دول مجلس التعاون
والعراق من علاقات الراسخه مرتكزه على
الجوار الجغرافي والدين واللغه
وتعززها وشائج القربى والتاريخ المشترك
وتدفعها الاهداف المشاركه لبناء المستقبل
وتعزيز التنميه والسهم الجماعي
وانطلاقا من ذلك
فلقد حريص اصحاب الجلاله والسمو قائد
الدول المجلس حفظهم الله ورعاهم على تطوير
علاقات مجلس التعاون مع جمهوريه العراق في
كافه المجالات السياسيه والامنيه
والاقتصاديه والثقافيه وغيرها
مؤكدين ان ذلك ياتي كاولويه استراتيجيه
استجابه المتطلبات المستقبل وتعزيز للعمل
المشترك من خلال شراكه الاستراتيجيه بين
مجلس التعاون وجمهوريه العراق
ولقد اكد البيان الختام الصادر عن مقام
المجلس الاعلى للمجلس التعاون لدول الخليج
العربيه في دورته الثالثه والاربعين
والمنعقد في 9 ديسمبر 20 22 في الرياض على
مواقفي وقرارات مجلس التعاون الثابته تجاه
العراق الشقيق ودعم الجهود القائمه
لمكافحه الارهاب وتحقيق الامن والاستقرار
في العراق مشددا على اهميه الحفاظ على
سلامه ورحت تراضيه وسيادته الكامله وهويته
العربيه الاسلاميه ونسيج الاجتماعي ووحدته
الوطنيه
ومساندته لمواجهه الجماعات الارهابيه
والميليات المسلحه تكريسا لسياده الدوله
وانفاد القانون ورفض اي تدخلات خارجيه في
شؤون العراق
ولقد شهد العام الماضي عده اجتماعات في
مقر الامانه العامه في الرياض وفي بغداد
تنفيذا لخطه العمل المشتركه للفتره 20 19
20 24 بين مجلس التعاون والعراق في
المجالات السياسيه والامنيه والاقتصاديه
والثقافيه كما تم تاسيس لجنه مشتركه من
كبار المسؤولين لتنفيذ لمتابعه تنفيذ خطه
العمل ودعم المشاريع المشتركه حيث تشاهدنا
في يوليو 20 22 وعلى هامشي قمه جدتي
للتعاون والتنميه التوقيع على الاتفاقيه
ربط شبكه الكهرباء لدول مجلس التعاون مع
شبكه الكهرباء في جنوب العراق
ذلك بعد توفير الموارد الماليه اللازمه
لذلك واستكمال النواحي الفنيه للتنفيذ